[Music]
one of the ideas suggested as they open
it they pay a sort of a a prorated down
payment for the wall which I think
people agree that you need you need the
world in fact I see a lot of the
Democrats are all almost all of them are
breaking saying look wall so good it was
a good how is a wall more important than
families this shutdown is not a glitch
it is a crisis that the president alone
created and that the president alone can
end let's bring in our panel now Fox
News senior judicial analyst Judge
Andrew Napolitano national security
analyst morgan ortega and jonathan swan
national political reporter for Axios
the president they are asking for a
pro-rated down payment on his wall in a
continuing resolution which would fund
government for three weeks or so I did
the math really quickly five point seven
billion divided by 365 times twenty one
three hundred and twenty seven million
dollars he was can he can he get that
out of the Congress well I may have an
MBA but I cannot do math in my head the
way that you just did I did it on the
computer I think when the American
people are looking at this this is
devolved into a cafeteria food fight
with the Democrats in Congress saying
but he started it and and I think that's
why people are so frustrated I think
whatever a moral argument that Nancy
Pelosi the Democrats felt that they had
around Christmas or even two weeks ago
for me that has really evaporated in all
of this because you know there is no
point at this moment we have this many
resolutions come to the table that
you're not seeing
Democrats negotiate with the president
and this standoff is hurting real people
well there are there are real people
that that I am in the Navy Reserve that
I drill with that are federal agents
that that work at the UN in New York
these are friends of mine that have
children that are that are living
paycheck to paycheck because you know
they may have a wife or a husband at
home and so I think that it's time for
both sides of the aisle to get over
themselves and to get a real solution
here and you know this moral imperative
that the Democrats think they have I
think has been washed away it's time
it's time to come to the table is it
telling judge that the the democratic
measure just to open the government with
no money for the wall got two more votes
in the Senate than the president's plan
to yes it is very telling I was
surprised to see the six
publicans in the Senate go forth but I
want to pick up and what Morgan was
saying and not address the politics and
not address the morality but just
address the Constitution according to
congressman will heard former CIA agent
and conservative Republican through
whose district most of the wall would
pass the vast majority of that property
is not owned by the federal government
the President cannot condemn property on
his own he can't take property on his
own he can only do that with an Express
authorization from the Congress and
congressman Hurd says most of my
constituents are saying not in my
backyard what does that mean that means
litigation over the the value of each
parcel of property the president could
get seven point billion tomorrow he
won't be able to spend it for years
until the litigation is over with and
here's one of the other things about the
wall - in Texas because you have to
build it out of the Rio Grande
floodplain right these illegal migrants
coming up from Honduras who want to get
apprehended by the Border Patrol will
simply have to cross the river put feet
on American soil and it will be like
there was no barrier there once their
feet are on Americans so that protected
by due process
so Jonathan Morgan was saying that
tomorrow federal workers will miss their
second pay period and and for a lot of
people this really is going to begin to
bite so how do you read the political
pressure and how it's growing and who is
it really putting pressure on Congress
or the president it's really hard to say
because but the president is seeing the
Coast Guard for example not getting paid
and they've tried to hotline a bill to
pay them through the Senate that the
military is certainly Trump says that is
his constituency he said this publicly
that a lot of these federal workers are
Democrats so he does sort of distinguish
in some ways about that and obviously
the Democrats a lot of these you know
basically this is their constituents and
particularly members from states with
lots of federal workers Maryland
Virginia others so there there is
pressure on both sides but the
leadership is so dug in Nancy Pelosi has
said that walls themselves are immoral
so for her to then give him money for
something called a wall is then off the
table or even you know steel slats or
whatever but so is off the table taking
down the immoral wall that already
exists along that sure bits try to have
it both
so you now have this situation I was
talking to someone in the White House
today about this and they're saying well
Democrats are now saying maybe we'll
give you 5.7 billion for things along
the border but not barriers and war
that's not going to cut it that's
everything that except for what Trump
really wants president's re-election
campaign members and you're watching
these past two weeks I think you're
elated because any thought that you have
that the Democrats might moderate and
nominate someone like Biden and try to
be responsible if this is the behavior
that we've seen over the last two weeks
going into 2020 the president's
re-election campaign must feel great
however there seems to be a little bit
of a disconnect here I won't want to
jump ahead and replace something that
Wilbur Ross said this morning that even
the president said he could have said
better and then the way Wilbur Ross
walked it back this afternoon was in
here the banks and the credit union
should be making credit available to
them these are basically government
guaranteed loans
we're aware painfully aware that there
are hardships inflicted on the
individual workers well I was trying to
do is make sure that they're aware that
there are possible other things that
could help somewhat mitigates their
problems so there's a judge that the the
administration is trying to take the
moral high ground here to say we know
that workers are hurting but it's
important that we get border security
and then Wilbur Ross comes and says well
I don't know why they can't get a loan I
think he really cut the ground out from
under the president there I mean the
world in which he lives he can call up
his banker and get a loan for almost
anything that he wants but the federal
government workers cannot do that I mean
it's one thing to say well you work for
the federal government it's bankrupt
what do you expect there are times when
it can't pay their bills it's another
thing to say what's wrong with you go
borrow the money nobody accepts that as
a reasonable response right now State of
the Union the president we've had his
heels dug in
he sent the note back to Nancy Pelosi
yesterday I'll see you on the 29th as
scheduled she wrote him back no you
won't and then we heard that there was
going to be a plan B late last night the
president tweeted as the shutdown was
going on Nancy Pelosi asked me to give
the State of the Union address I agreed
she then changed her mind because of the
shutdown suggesting a later date this is
her prerogative I will do the address
when the shutdown is
I'm not looking for an alternative venue
for the State of the Union address I
mean he got the political capital
Jonathan of making her disinvite him
right but then does he lose by saying
you know what she's right I don't know I
mean I was sort of out of character for
Trump and I texted this stuff you know
exactly it was it was quite surprising
to see him do that and I try to is there
some backstory here is it political get
the two things I've learned is one there
were real logistical issues with a lot
of these other options but also more
than that and I heard this from people
who discuss if Trump is he likes the
tradition he really likes the the what
the house was bigger yeah pretty good
and he didn't want to give up the the
pomp in the circumstance of the house so
I think that was really they always got
to wait a little while he's got away all
right